hey everyone I'm Curtin Davina and
joining me today is will Poulter he is
gonna be in the next dark pictures
anthology little hope so will thank you
so much for being here no no that's all
mine thanks for having me
so this isn't your first rodeo with
games or at least you've been in
Bandersnatch part of that and now this
and I'm curious personally about the
overlap there or if there is any and
major differences between being in a
choose-your-own-adventure Netflix movie
game and then something like what
supermassive games is known for sure
yeah I think the crossover at least from
a creative standpoint if I sort of hold
the two projects up side-by-side is is
that they're both inherently cinematic
and although they kind of follow the the
structure of a game and obviously it's
largely kind of gamer or active viewer
let you know the game little hope like a
lot of the games across the dark pages
anthology are very filmic there's a real
emphasis on authentic performances and
on a really kind of intriguing film like
narrative and that was cool
I think honestly I found sort of
entertaining all the different kind of
potential choices when it came to
shooting Bandersnatch really really
difficult and that was because we shot
sort of out of continuity
whereas with little ho although we had
to you know entertain lots of different
choices lucky that you know we were kind
of able to pretty much even in sequence
so made it that's habit easier did you
have you done motion capture before it
was my first time doing like an entirely
motion capture based performance I've
done sort of small elements of motion
capture but not going like this what was
the like the the main transition I mean
of course the obvious of which you're
you know spandex ooh and you have
nothing to work with but like you just
mentioned with with Bandersnatch and
certain continuity issues and shooting
out of order and also you have to worry
about the elements of what it's like to
shoot on a set what is that like for you
as an actor to work only in motion
capture were there any advantages stuff
like that yeah you know I found it it
was a really fun buys and imagination
you know I actually read
enjoyed the fact that without set or
without props you know you were kind of
left to create a lot of it in your mind
and there's something you know strangely
sort of freeing about that it would seem
like it was sort of a limitation but it
but it but it wasn't and I really
enjoyed it the thing that I had to sort
of get used to was the pace and the pace
that we moved that was pretty was pretty
intense that was something that I wasn't
I wasn't used to I thought TV pace was
was heavy but game game making paces is
like sprint work right and especially
like you know the the cliche like I mean
having movie says you have it's it's
every single time you do something you
have to take a break you have to reset
up you have to breathe do things and in
this case you can just pick up from
where you left off which must have been
a grueling exercise I'm sure yeah yeah
it was definitely one thing that I find
fascinating has you done midsummer
you've done Bandersnatch and now you
know little hope is on its way there's
like this theme of horror kind of
trickling in some of your recent
performances
what is it having done those things on
camera what was the process like for
having to evoke horror or the reaction
of horror when you're a motion capture
when you have nothing to work with right
right I think you find yourself really
leading on your castmates a lot you know
in order to sort of make you feel
authentic and and really kind of you
know conjure up that that horror I mean
you know in in every aspect of the
performance that the script and indeed
our director Nick Nick Bohan you know
encouraged us to go for authenticity you
know he was a stickler for that and if
anything seemed on naturalistic or sort
of too theatrical he'd reel us right
back which is which is great in that
sense it was you know every bit like a
like a film but then when it came to you
know the horror and I think our
reactions to the horrifying things he
really wanted us to go for it and not
hold back and I think the reason being
is that these games like pretty much all
of the games in the anthology they are
focused on
ordinary people put under unimaginable
you know stress and in terrifying
circumstances so stands to reason that
our reactions would be what they are and
that was that was really cool you know
that was that was really nice to know
that you could just kind of trust your
instincts and react to things naturally
and you'd be serving the project to the
best of your ability I feel like it's
got to be as you mentioned like a
testament the people you work with and
the and the ability to evoke this
imagination there's these things that
you cannot see on a more on a more game
ish side you and I and I apologize we
keep going back to like midsummer
Bandersnatch but there's no this this
these these these things that I find
super fascinating that are like aligning
in this place so you you play they'll be
a this kind of acclaimed game maker and
one thing in Bamberg bench is there
anything you grew out of appreciation
from that role now having and of course
it's from you know portraying a
character from a different time period
but um is there anything you internalize
or anything you were able to appreciate
now working on a game internally opposed
to portraying a person who's making
games yeah it's it's interesting you
know it wasn't until very very recently
that I said fooled that link or someone
pointed out to me that you know you
played a games developer and you've been
a character in a game and I thought you
know the project he played a games
developer in was also you know multi
strand inherits a
choose-your-own-adventure site and that
kind of I had it set a little bit of a
mind-blowing moment I feel like the
folks behind black marrow may still be
watching me to be honest but I I think
it did certainly helped me appreciate
just how far you know games have come in
terms of their development and you know
and the advent of Technology in the
gaming world I know from some of my
research in preparation for Bandersnatch
how you know fairly basic sort of games
you know made on the spectrum were
blowing people's minds across you know
bedrooms around the country when they
when they first that it came out and
there
you know people went from playing those
in their bedrooms on relatively
rudimentary kind of simple consoles to
now having these incredibly immersive
sort of film epic experiences like like
the one you know that's offered in the
shape of little holes so it definitely I
think helped me grow my appreciation for
just how far it's come
what's in a kind of with that aspect and
like that that in the back your mind
what is the what is it like for knowing
that players that people are have a
stake in what happens to you as a
character in a way that you otherwise
can't grasp
you know there's if I curate otherwise
audience members are by curiously
watching things happen to you but in
this case it's kind of it's quite
literally in their hands on what happens
to you is there any is is there was
there any sort of thought probably that
like how did that feel is that something
that crossed your mind or the very idea
of watching or even controlling yourself
in that scenario yeah definitely I think
it adds to the sense of suspense you
know the the threat as well and really
the the kind of shock and horror of it
when it could potentially goes wrong and
a choice that you make leads you down a
pathway towards you know doom or
something like it and that and that's
that's also a really intriguing thing
that comes with you know I think
interactive mediums and the world of
gaming it's intriguing to think about
how we can utilize that to I think make
the experience of accessing whatever the
message is more sort of palpable you
know the more immersive the experience I
think the greater the opportunity for
for empathy and for you know the
understanding of other experiences that
are different to your own so it's um
it's exciting to think how that
technology is going to be used and the
role that games you know will play in
that are you are you bummed out at all
when you see but I though you're making
a choices as a player or you have to
witness what somebody does that has an
impact on your character in any way you
know what that's what I think gaming has
over traditional Phil
television is that when you watch a
horror film and you're screaming and the
characters to make better choices don't
go through that door the nice thing is
as a gamer you know you have that you
have that choice you're responsible for
you know whatever branch you want to
explore in your narrative and it puts
the power in the hands of the the person
who has the controller right and
especially with supermassive games
specifically there's so many branching
ways and so many different things you
can do and characters are introduced
they're characters that are introduced
fairly early on can die quite quickly
after depending on you play and of
course like you know we have the the
privilege of being able to like play the
game multiple times and see how
scenarios work out but is there is there
does the idea in any way like kind of
bum you out that you might die early on
in the story and then people won't get
to see kind of like the branch or work
you've done going forward in the game
and the in the story of the game yeah I
mean in the interest of authenticity
it's important to point out that like
every character can die but you know by
the same token like every character can
conserve I've as well so the nice thing
obviously is that you can go back and
try again
I dunno what you mean I mean you know
sometimes when you hear about you know
different people's experiences you think
ah shoot you know I wish you'd made this
choice of where she made that but it's
kind of the beauty of it that people can
have you know a range of different
experiences and the thing that's
especially cool about little hope for me
is there's this mysterious quality you
know throughout the whole throughout the
whole game that kind of lives in the fog
that sort of defines a little hope and
you're constantly trying to work out you
know what's going on there are constant
unnerving reminders that not all is what
it seems and I think one of the tasks
that people really enjoy is trying to
work out how the different time periods
and how the various characters all link
towards you know or sorry all linked to
each other is there any certain
difference in preparation for a role
like this you mentioned earlier you did
a lot of research for Bandersnatch and
kind of looking at that era and games
and how that worked and in this case
you're playing a college student and a
field trip
the beyond like the the the character
the things that define the character
you're playing what is just the general
preparation difference between working
on film and working in a videogame it's
interesting so I'm responsible for three
characters in the film sorry in the game
that's how filmic it is in the game yes
sorry yeah Andrew who exists in the
present day and is the student as you
mentioned Anthony who exists in the
1970s and then a character called
Abraham who exists in 1692 and I think
that really I wouldn't say that there
are any major differences I think in
order to distinguish between the three
characters I had to come up with sort of
characterization all sort of
characteristics for each of them so that
they could be set apart mer Anthony is a
little bit sort of more immature and
slightly younger Abraham of the sea
existing in a totally different time
period had a totally different way of
conversing and indeed a different accent
with a sort of greater disparity to his
accent between what Andrew and Anthony's
was so little things like that that you
have to take into consideration you know
any with any role you play but because
there were three of them it was more
about making them distinct from each
other the the thing leaked to the gaming
experience sort of rather the experience
of making the game was when those
characters interacted with each other
and then you have to consider okay what
would this character how would he
present himself to that character so
sometimes I play a well there was one
scene where I played Abraham talking to
Andrew and Andrew talking to Abraham and
that was that was a bit of a brain
scramble when you're not filming when
you're not making a game or and the
other thing what do you play what are
you doing the off time and he games the
off time
yeah you know what I'm honestly I'm not
a huge gamer and kind of never was but I
was that kid who used to watch other
people game I used to be that person who
you know would happily pass the pad and
watch people play and I think I enjoyed
it from a narrative perspective more
than more than anything else and also I
just wasn't very good again I was always
the guy to like lose a life or you know
choose the wrong option so I was a happy
spectator and that's I mean that's
really quite amazing
given the the games that you chose to
you know that they you and you somehow
find yourself in to was an interactive
narrative driven game which is amazing
so yeah are you I mean it's it's it is
that something you're gonna try you're
gonna try and play are you at least
gonna see what it's like to get through
a little hope or you're gonna pass it to
someone and watch my shoulders and Judge
Larry movements with your characters are
a hundred percent I mean it'd be a good
test this sort of like friendship
loyalty or family loyalty if I just
watched watched my friends a family play
and see if they would like you know try
to keep me alive or not but um no I am I
am wanting to play it desperately I've
seen a lot of the gameplay and the game
looks absolutely incredible so I'm I'm
desperate to give it a go and and it's
out in the fall and can't wait to can't
wait to do that in any case if there's
anything more that you want to add or
say in terms of little hope and what we
can expect I know you mentioned out in
the fall but anything else you want to
add well no no just thanks very much for
having me Co and hope people enjoy the
game absolutely cool
well thanks everyone I was current Avena
this is will Poulter for everything
little hope and dark pictures anthology
keep it here at GameSpot
[Music]
you
[Music]